this hearing continued and now let's
take someone on the other side of this
debate this is Kelly Robinson who
identifies as the first queer black
president of the Human Rights Campaign
and here she is defending dudes in girls
Sports
women that are biology mail
has a physical advantage in sports over
a biological female not as a definitive
statement
give me an example well no I I don't
think
how many female members of the NBA do
you see well I can say that you know
there's been this news article about men
that think that they could beat Serena
Williams in tennis right that they think
that they could actually score a point
on her and it's just not the case she is
stronger than that what's your
experience been
male female both Serena and Venus lost
to the 203rd ranked male tennis player
which they're phenoms for women my
experience my husband he swam at
University of Kentucky as well in terms
of accolades and in terms of national
ranking I was a much better swimmer than
him he could kick my butt any day of the
week without trying
okay so here you have the black queer
head of the Human Rights Campaign saying
that Serena Williams could beat men in
women's uh beat men in tennis right just
if you put a woman against a man in
tennis it took us about 10 seconds to
find this video which we've shown you
before here's Serena Williams on females
versus males in tennis
well actually it's funny because Andy
Murray he oh he was been joking about
myself and him playing a match and I'm
like Andy seriously like are you kidding
me because for me tennis and men's
tennis and women's sins are completely
almost two separate Sports so I'm like
if I were to play Andy Murray I would
lose 6060 and five to six minutes maybe
10 minutes because no it's true
completely it's a completely different
word the men are a lot faster and me and
um they they get they serve harder they
hit hard it's just a different game and
I love to play women's tennis and I I
only want to play girls because I don't
want to be embarrassed I would not do
the tour I wouldn't do Billie Jean any
justice so Andy stop it yeah we're not
gonna I'm not gonna let you kill me I'm
with you when it comes to tennis I only
want to play girls yeah
all right that's a good line Letterman I
miss him
um look there you have arguably the
greatest female tennis player saying
it's not even the same sport men are
stronger they serve faster they hit the
the ball harder like it's obvious
everyone knows it and people always go
when is this thing going to end right
like what is rock bottom with this thing
and I'm telling you there will be a rock
bottom and my guess is it's going to be
something like this there is going to be
a 37 or 38 year old washed up because 37
38 you're washed up if you're an NBA
player male basketball player I'm
talking somebody who's probably six
eight 280 scoring two points a game
never particularly good but you know
size wise could just make it to the NBA
he's going to retire and he is going to
suddenly give himself the name Angela
and he is going to score 35 points a
game grab 12 rebounds and eight assists
a game in the WNBA and they will Crown
the WNBA MVP
a guy named Angela that is how this
thing will eventually implode but you
you see how insane it is the woman and
the woman I should say so on one hand
Riley on the other hand Serena the women
that have to face off against men they
know reality but the activist the
activists want to re-jigger everything
the way they want it to be organized and
that really is the problem here